a little later than advertised you are
joining an Android developer office
hours so committee live from London my
name is Nick butcher and i'm joined by
Matt gaunt hey and I'm Richard Hyndman
also from the Android developer
relations team so this is your
opportunity to talk to us about all
things android dev and as always this is
not an opportunity to talk about I'm
really product when it's X feature gonna
launch and why is rich in that showing
and headphones let their titties on the
bus as easily topics will not be
discussed but otherwise yet come along
and ask this all things android and yeah
so it looks like a joined by a couple of
regular watchers who are we got into
hangout live say hello hey going foul
Hale house again mr. Chilton who else to
have a license mushroom love you it's a
pretty big sort of thing and time um
what I'll help you like to see what I
did it I'm gonna go eat today and news
and hitting the news of the moment we
won't talk about exciting android
developments something tailored to
Napier I'm still just like up here on
the fact that Android apps can have
awesome apps in the magnetic so in-app
billing in VV to love you has launched
has anyone had a chance to look at the
new streamlined easier way to make
in-app payments I have yep I with it
Matt's been playing in as well yeah what
do you think of it much improved yes
many many fewer time lines of code to
implement yeah much much simpler much
easier training to really good as well
yeah you don't have a full thing in 50
lines of code man back just below the
feedback I've had that there is love the
kind of monetization opportunities it
affords them but find it hard to
implement a having the old version in
the automation on the elevation and you
can finally request the pricing
information from the Play Store so
inside your application you can say by a
solid 4 99 cent why you put sales on in
the Play Store it just comes down into
application yet we don't have to
synchronize a change to your queue
priceless weird
I check and update your app and hope
user gets it though it's absolutely the
right price yet it's much so long
hopefully that reduces the number of
cancellations as well because they won't
go through to the place they can see the
price in your app before going to the
Play Store i'm finding out yeah their
cost of Lee you know item okay I haven't
checked today's moderator out but I'm
sure we have some questions on it and
what's a while yeah i don'ti and
questions from people in the Hangout
before we jump into the moderator I've
got one bar I don't know whether you
guys can actually answer it it's based
on the new Android tools has a new
license term which question that they
care doing fragmentation of Android is
there any guidance on what would be
considered fragmentation saying ow you
kind of there was a lotta noise to admit
that you mind repeating sure the new
android toolkit for I think it's for 4.2
has a clause in the license that says it
can't be used to for anything that would
contribute to fragmentation is there
anywhere that we can get dark guidance
on what will be considered fragmentation
and what's not so you talking about the
Terms of Service which sounds like it's
a lot like a voyage into loyal and which
I am not qualified to make any kind of
value judgment upon there's a good
question though so those the change in
the terms of service your greeting when
you up this to ADT right yep yea though
I don't know have you posted this in and
the tools development forum I haven't is
it there was a discussion in the tools
development because if you build the
tools from the open source project due
course not bound by the same license so
there was logged turn your frown on that
but it's just basically looking for a
definition of what fragmentation means
in that context yeah yeah like let's do
a good question which unfortunately I
think any of us even though or quite by
to weigh in on unfortunately how could
we get an answer to that I guess maybe
we email the PM for that project and try
and find out we could try leave that
with us we'll try and follow up on that
way cool thanks no problem any other
live questions in the room a very quick
one liveleak very quick and in terms of
Google Play error codes do you guys know
or does anyone else know
you these kind of 91 for error codes
which sure we had yesterday throughout
the entire market or 948 to stir they
seemed really kind of random and we
would love to tell I uses What's Wrong
referred them buying our apps wedding I
all I know is that there was an outage
at some point any good result yeah some
pain okay fine yep it will show the 914
we have quite a lot of partners
reporting it I've used to be in there
right okay but yeah st is there anything
XP you can do in UF no i don't think
there's any we don't like publishers era
potent advice any kind of response to
puts the years I've sages caption
basically internet okay there was an
error dragon we are we update the known
issues page as well if you do a Google
search with google played known issues
we have pretty horrible cases updated
service you can show your users that
it's it's our apartment right okay yes I
scruton suppose how you're doing Peter
you've been a lurker for a while first
time I left oh I looked last week and
only just found about it out only was
found out about it recently so join you
guys in the future yep spread the way
one often yeah we could placing the
Android developers community on Google+
yeah we should mm-hmm we listen to more
people seem to have joined us as well so
we got there yeah she goes droning ought
to the visor and Giuseppe of course
anyway oh yeah you go I think he had a
question in the moderator right I
actually had to but the most important
one was the 1i that already posted on
google+ while ago and was the question
about the voice recognition is streaming
stuff i couldn't find any documentation
on it but I what I would like to do is
absolutely up Google now app is doing is
like listen for a certain kind of work
so I think the voice recognition could
be useful for that but I'm not sure if I
can started in a sort of stream
background way in my up there's no way
to do really the only way you can please
by throwing up the the recognition
dialogue there's no connect background
recognition ok so the would also require
either a custom I me or something like
that because quite possibly I don't even
know if he's successful that way i think
in you know the custom I me froze up the
standard go i right the Dodger you okay
yep so you can either do fixed length
detection and then process not very good
i think it's a crazy just like a second
I consulates are we going on which is my
deal or okay fine am I that I knew not
going to know what I want yeah vaguely
ah pree drags just come in predrag it's
just coming from the Hangout post cool
excellent and you had a second question
here yeah but that's what was regarding
the the new billing API maja just a
confirmation I assume that in the new
billing API your old purchases will also
pop up right I like to if you have
managed purchase backwards compatible
the new items EG create you now and it'd
be managed right because i read some
some comments and twitter that something
broke but i'm not sure what so I think I
don't let's ask yeah I saw that as well
we're all states a bleep yeah yeah you
said so I'm not sure what's going on
there but I from what I understand later
that he's still using the older API and
that broke for him but I haven't noticed
that in my app yet so we shouldn't have
changed anything if you're still saying
v1 or v2 it should still have v1 v2
functionality it's only as soon as you
specified v3 that you'll get new post
policy yeah okay cool cool so if there
any more live questions in the room or
should we jump into the moderator yeah I
want to ask you white why the android is
the victim I was
so why should you develop for android
rovner us yeah listen I guess it's the
world's largest offer mobile operating
system is a pretty compelling reason
they say if Reach is important to you
then you busted yeah I have a good
article if you wanted to read yes to go
to chat window hmm they're still getting
tangled it this is top left corner you
have a little chat button then you can
press it on with the window like nothing
this is the dude I mean it's mitts
article from three years ago but still
pretty good one all right well thanks
for watching 11 whether the same 75% of
all smartphone shipping run Android
that's a pretty strong reason I think
here has a lot of good reasons yeah the
biggest the biggest reason for me is
that you don't need to wait like two
three weeks to get your app in store yes
mummification and yeah it's especially
crazy if you want to publish out these
existing afton and like Apple that bored
there are people that abandoned their
app because that would imply yam you
have your own software any cycles which
is awesome and it's a whole ecosystem as
well it's under control by one company
we have all the OEMs the operators that
your handset manufacturers for
developers people with their own music
stores that have stores everything built
and I'm tried to create this massive
ecosystem people working together
recently came care remember it correctly
close and massively back thanks cool I
think this is a pretty open end quit in
the questioner to spend all I there yeah
it's been a long time since I that's why
it's morally a how now how do i do you
act but thanks to the question hopefully
those are some convincing arguments
worry any more likely she's also we go
back into the moderator I have a
question which is also in the moderator
it's about a three page view which I
would like to implement and just like
that
d my ass so one on the left side and one
on the right side and if you choose any
content on the right side you get this
slider which just slides over one of
those fragments and then there's some
content without using an external
library like without using any external
library so see what a build-it-yourself
ok so basically those will just be
fragment animations ok so every time you
kind of you know in gmail so when you
select an individual message it'll cure
the set of animations where I'll slide
out the label view and letting it slide
in the detail view ok is there an
example or any code available to try
something like that out or yeah sure
there is and one that I was really good
when there is the romanji published so
we called x-large demos if you look if
you google for a monkey x live demos he
did it this was like not to walk back
now when honeycomb just launched but it
was a really nice demonstration of how
to use fragments and how to animate them
around since then the animation you guys
only got better and stronger and faster
and so on so you know there's a few
you improvement so you can use things
like adapters and so on ok so that was
it sir so I think that demos don't like
x-large demos you know like the screen
modifier screen size 15 x-large ok thank
you for watching yeah you're welcome
classic android 3 animation domination
sighs my 5x lodged who miss Elaine's my
guys have a time shifted version of us
in your window yeah any other questions
look fly from the hangout or she would
crack on with the moderator will go to a
fertile time no so Timothy kissed in
Swansea says how can I show the youth
that the user can't swipe a certain way
in a viewpager like over scrolling how
do i force over scrolling when the
viewpager not at the end what would you
use the hospital for this right I don't
know what you mean when the view page is
not the end so you want to kind of
arbitrarily cut them off before they can
get to the end the last view perhaps
yeah and it kind of sounds like if you
had a wizard you might not want to
enable them to go to the third pain
until they complete it certain criteria
on the second pain so my guess would be
to just do this in the adapter using
some tricky stuff just to say there's
only two few pages and then once they've
completed it then fire off and change
the adapt let's say okay now the third
one's available now run that it was a
temp like you you can always meet them
okay it's my yeah you could ever
ID on touch as well beyond touch events
and just decide whether or not you're
gonna passengers in the viewpager so if
they have not completed the requisite
whatever it comes on the form just Oh
miss video game actually if you haven't
done it it's really really worth taking
a look at a few pages sources it could
have been readable and you'll learn a
lot about how to create custom views but
yeah if you look at the section wait
just a touch dragging it decides where
to do it you know get done data to get
that new view or not you could then just
info
the edge effect stuff instead to get the
force field blow at that point hopefully
that's answer your question live here
the adaptive you sound like the right
way to go ok I'll seem to be going
through an adding timed YouTube two
responses each of the questions as a
very busy and games remaining times oh
my Chris pants today hey there thinking
just in case I mr. the first time round
okay Richie seem to be the Hangout twice
I am yes Harry Hank double rich this
week that's what happens on with
unprepared and we get a campus light and
so this question here from giuseppe do
you want to a mutant Oscars live
Giuseppe yes hey how do i send for a
little bitty hello we can hear you fine
Giuseppe hi I can't get good good good I
just put my to that question to the
moderators burner if if you want I can
ask here I would like to i would like to
know in the case of situation where l
well the license failed I mean that
actually we have about 20,000 real users
that paid the application but because we
have a Beca back-end server we know that
there are about three hundred thousand
euros three hundred thousand users that
they just downloaded the application
from aptoide is an appetite this is just
a center of crackers they will move with
the elf were a license from the
application and they make done without
proper the application from everybody
the bad situation at the moment is that
the Play Store is making possible this
aptoide exists as there is a
the client on the Play Store and this is
not very very good what is your point of
view I would like to know oh yeah well
first of all as the Pirates amounts
highest order from google i/o which
explains how to secure your LVL pass the
standardization what we have securing
LVL is a among an in-depth topic if you
put more if it's to it but it's worth
quite in your application especially in
your case we applied a valuable
application hackers aren't going to
spend more time trying to break it and
get that that valuable app back out into
the wild but as Hugo says you've got
your own servers that you to the
application I let me try and maintain
the list of authorized Apps users on
those servers and whenever you get a
pirated out used to save it for the
salad another thing that I'd recommend
is looking at proguard or even going for
eric level tunes more commercial
offering decks guard which is focused on
Android that makes it even more
difficult to extract out things like LVL
and other routines and bits and bobs
like that so if the app hasn't been fed
through at least proguard then it's
definitely worth giving that a shot
absolutely nothing else mentioned the
Pirates and no place if you were office
gated your raptures happy yes has been a
fabu skated by in with the product um I
have an echo probably someone have a
microphone open I think this guy Patrick
Patrick ok let's continue um well the
domain that the main solution as it we
everybody knows here is just to use our
back-end server I would like to use the
backend server is just to get the itch
itch or chase stall the purchase in our
back-end server and the Trudel account
manager compared if the users has been
booked but in my special case of as you
remember we don't we can use the API of
a check out because there is available
only in UK in the USA and so this
solution
is not applicable for us the the code
has been a skate everything does be done
the check license it's not always in any
update in the same position of the code
I used to change the position of the
license checking some time in some
activity sometime in some fragments
sometimes somewhere else awesome
preference everywhere I tried elders
open all that my small mind can suggest
butter but I given to find out who said
it well someone told me just that they
never mind about these people because
the people that want the crack it up
will never pay you for the application
yes that is good suggesting but the
technical problem is very important
because actually my back-end server it's
it's a it's giving your right
downloading serving information about so
I have the ninety seven percent of the
users that are using the my AdWords my
resource 40 for nothing that means the
situation I believe that it's the time
to find some solution for this problem
that's all probably mine could be not
the right and a question seems to be not
a question but is a way here to open the
discussion between us that's it yeah he
tried I file is the labor of application
sorry Patrick what is the name of
application like I believe that he risen
not the right place to to say the names
of our application we are not here for
advertising if you want to later by we
like to you know yeah the just curious
look further in the problem yeah yeah if
you go if you go on up tight uptight
website then in the music category my
application is the first one so you
cannot wrong okay simple nice
so have you tried it I would like I
would like I would like to say that my
application is the first on the play
store not on that pathologist or have
you tried other recommendations in the
Tokra talked about there they're talking
goodbye are they in pirate pirates and
vampires bitch talks about exactly this
problem problem yes so you try to
verifying the signatures of device on
your server in all this change this into
exchange the numbers that any version i
change the numbers no no way no way i
tried to encrypt the the iar the device
ID I tried it will encrypt the day
everything every right they just remove
they just remove the check when they
find what is my do check and they don't
know voodoo do check and then they
return true anytime it's very simple i
have already downloaded from aptoide by
APK and i understood very well how they
do that so i can try to follow any
guidelines but i will not find the
solution if we continue to use add well
as a system that's it do you have a free
version of your application and then
allow people to purchase very nap oh no
we have into the free version because
that might be a solution because a lot
of the times you'll find people are
trying the application out to see if
they like it it just from taking it from
another perspective it might be worth
switching to in-app payments and
offering a small free trial to get
people hooked Jen and then get them to
buy once they're happy that they like
the application rather than sort of
giving them the only choices pay up
beforehand or go and get it from a
pirate site yes but hourly you must be a
DVD me that this is adjusted workaround
is not the DL solution to the problem
right it's not a technical solution to
the problem but from the statistics I've
seen there's a lot less there's a lot
more conversion to customers a lot more
purchases when you switch to something
like in-app billing with the Free Bet up
the front which could be a way to yeah
what
cure the problem but you certainly find
that you're getting a lot more paid
users on your server and so you may get
to the stage where you're talking 50 50
or even a t20 paid versus unpaid yes
that's true that's true yeah I think
that's a great night it's good it's good
to suggest him but frankly eie I hope
that someday we can get also the
technical solution anyway ever to have
any way verifying which uses contacting
your servers have paid in which happened
yes look at you okay I don't I do that I
do that yes I check each check check I
know from where they downloaded the
application and if they download the apk
from the google market because there are
a constant inside the application but
the only that i can do it's when i
upgrade to new version just to look to
block the old version this will act on
what i am doing now but because the
users didn't use it to upgrade to the
new version very fast some time uncool
in the problem to block users that have
paid the 14 have you look to check up
reporting the signature the APK file to
your server and only responding to
requests from an APK that's been signed
with the right signature oh i list you
can repeat again please sure using the
package manager you can get the
signature for your APK or the APK that's
running now it should be able to report
that to your server and it will only
report your signature for application
versions which don't have your check
removed ie you've authored new
distributors so if people are removing
it re-signing the APK in order to get it
installed you'll probably find that the
signatures that get reported to your
server are not the ones you're expected
and so you could just block those users
straight off the chipra that is that
they can easily replace that code
and just return what the proper
signatures you think correct grease
correct and don't you ever gonna fix it
because it's always gonna be code which
is out your control it's always gonna be
on their device they can always get to
change it so it never can completely fix
it and and I think I'll fit you just
have to bother bullet and just accept it
okay okay can I can I II just put here
one of my idea and each of us tried to
see if it's correct when the device
download the apk from the Play Store
okay he replaced or more the device ID
in that moment okay what is the problem
for Google to give us in the back hand
information the device ID then we can
collect this your device ID we can store
somewhere in our server and to compare
with the each window with the buyer I
don't know from my question is we
accelerate to the buyer though you might
have especially now with multiple
multiple users on a single tablet your
counselor single tablet it's a is the
account the gmail account is purchased
it normally the guys and then how would
you use that you mean you're proposing
to send a device idea of each request
your server is then you just get in the
same situation that Chris talked about
where they'll find a valid device ID and
just always send that you mean they
can't change the device ID to know they
can send the device ID which is known
good mr. Nicholas part because I'm going
to use the NDK a lot in your application
if you've gone as far as during the APK
signature checks in the NDK in the
native library that you can pile off
because it's very much other for the
decompile and we can strike that part of
the application and then just disable
the whole application is the native
library check fails you take which
signature your app to side with the
hatch of the entire APK file opens up
back this is me sir
a Richard is there any of the suggested
the solution orale working and
guaranteed that there will be not crack
no there's nothing in the world that's
not being cracked right what has a
secure system yes anything it's not
secure computing platform you're not in
control of the hardware right nothing
craigy but we just yeah we just to make
harder for them to make this make it
hard it's a crack at than your
application is worth all of security is
just about an effort reward ratio and
it's making the effort so high in the
reward so low that people don't think
it's worth doing I really think that the
idea of going free event purchase is a
really really good idea actually as well
I think yeah yeah when you make it so
easy to get access to the application
and very easy to pay to connect like if
you proven you like it then I think that
removes some of the curiosity pipe
piracy yeah it's just hard to figure out
especially in this kind of application
how much of the functionality you give
away for free as users will install it
expecting to do a certain other things
and then you might able to do that you
pro upgrade please buy the appointment
ends yes so you've got to still get
bounced right because you could lose a
lot of ratings on it yeah it's not
trivial but it's worth it ok ok thank
you very much since then there's been a
big conversation going on chat we know
that I'm rereading the ankles be
generated I just don't have idea how
they managed to change obfuscating code
whenever I decompile I'm scared it up
it's a mess it's easy it's cuz they're
linked ok let's just rip out the android
java checks check out the droids on UK
videos for example for IDK yeah it was a
presentation on hacking word with
friends or something like that yeah
reverse engineering for fun and profit
or something up yeah it was a very cool
thing but it's only show which also
shows how easy it is if you have it's
just the matter of time that you put in
it I think you need a lot of these
checks and NDK is Rachel yes so sorry
yeah and I'm not sure for how LDL works
but couldn't you just send the response
my LVL to your server and then do
something with that too
Fyodor yeah that's what I suggesting X
it is signed with your public key right
right now but that pit in the middle
well yeah because it goes from our
service to your application in your
servers little bit away your application
gets hold of it can you say yeah but you
could also just check if if it if it
found home at all if someone you remove
step check and it doesn't phone home of
it or its phones home with the same
value all the time that could mean it
make it a bit harder yeah never be
perfect it's always going to be here
just make it a bit harder bit adders
yeah hopefully at some point it's not
enough other people leave the stock LVL
implementation inside their application
as well some people think they're
correct it but then they have a more
secure in that cool and one other thing
that and one other thing that they do
informs about if you try to spend for
example for the spammer it looks like
everything works but in reality stuff
doesn't work so I can imagine in and for
this particular application that maybe
some things work and some things just
don't work if the text that you have the
correct yeah one of my favorite ones is
a partner with who when they detect some
as a pirate they don't tell well do
anything they just make it impossible to
finish that level yeah yeah the baddies
are something like a rock hard there's
one I saw that enabled the game but
after playing for an hour or two you
actually got a pop-up that took you to
the Play Store and said if you want to
continue you can have to buy it it's
just quite nice way of doing things fair
enough i say that's addicted yeah
exactly yeah if you pop up the thing
saying you're a filthy pirate people are
going to get all defensive and like you
know not going to be inclined to buy but
if you say hey look you've been playing
for two and a half hours now you've got
this much programs which will keep for
you to freaking pay the night and I be
and don't forget the picture of you with
a begging bowl something like that I
guess anyway we've been on piracy for a
long time let's move on oh sorry several
units are getting such esta pgina I
like the question of the Peter Brooks
has the Google service API dropped the
Play Store transaction this is a this is
something that seems to be interesting
i miss that in the cyber has the one has
added google service API got placed or
transactions yeah yeah yeah if the
google play services cultura tune back
in the API the transactions probably we
can double check e for the application
as a being paid or is using something
different no I don't need this sorry not
provide a protection because if you put
your socialize for facebook management
application in up purchase you can get
the list of places that cal yes correct
that way but again you're still gonna
then go on to the root of them stepping
in the middle and just saying yet he's
paid so yeah but the new place oaks
there's no doesn't have anything fun
aight obligations all of you your
externally and try and check it is there
check out ITI could ya please please
check I a check out the hippie is not to
use a full 40 countries you know okay
yeah I do check out merchant support is
only in US and UK another you everything
correctly okay all right go well must
ask to do but will service API e team to
implement something for a transaction
tracking so please do that cool Wow top
of my hair moderate right now is a
windows 8 question no II going very rich
I don't know the answer I don't have
Windows 8 i've never tried windows 8 I
saw it in an airport once it is possible
to connect is it possible to collect an
Android for phone with Wi-Fi direct to a
Windows 8 PC using windows networking
proximity same question for Windows 7 PC
and namespace a pilot okay well Wi-Fi
direct is a standard rate later they
just don't move anything else then
that's it yeah I don't know what you'd
want to run over the Wi-Fi
necessary once you've connected your
device to your PC using my don't miss me
maybe again maybe sure yeah because 10
files are saying anything we clearly
have no idea all with these Wi-Fi direct
for his cooking phones up directly to
play games and things about I didn't
know does Wi-Fi discoveries I've never
connected to a PC elected to a TV I
guess with miracast runs over Wi-Fi
direct route if anybody has any
information on Windows 8 0 and Wi-Fi
direct send it to Cedric in Switzerland
there's only one okays earnest and the
moderator asked another favorite
question officers he wants to do a
horizontal list basically he was
replaced gallery and horizontal scroll
view and isn't an adaptive you and he
can't use view page it's showing
multiple views unless he's in external
lib apparently can you point me to a
good tutorial so there are a huge number
of horizontal this view implementations
out there on github and code google com
and so forth and each with their own
various implementations and drawbacks
and so forth has anyone used a good one
no it's on my list why I'm bringing your
horizontal list oh yes horizontal this
you know it's gonna make a horizontal
one at a time please and he's on the
list right all right worcester okay okay
once we've just dropped out as well go
to a webcam with you we will officially
be back in a second hopefully you can
still hear us somebody not if you can
hear us we can hear you the elegant
session in the Hangout now becomes
obvious it was only second to the chat
window as well I caught on one way or
another um so my impression I've taken
with Aras on to Chicago here in the past
has been to I've done it myself with
taking the gallery source code someone
actually taken that and wanted to add in
recycling abuse so there's example
somewhere stack overflow they've posted
a load of code if you really wanted to
get hands dirty that might be one way of
doing it but it's a lot of extra work if
you can find the library on github then
I'd stick with that that would because
of my only input on that
you
a little discipline yes I see too
strange to see you two later today what
happened no I was waiting for the
Hangout and the Hangout was late so I
went to do other stuff yeah we would
sorry about that we were seven minutes
late today because we were setting up in
the studio and I'm i have another excuse
let's handle for the next question in
the moderator so next question is what
is the reasoning behind making let the
method set text in textview final and
crisped has responded with my question
why you need to override the method it
is fair enough um yeah but why would it
be to find this final and yeah why would
you need to override it as a name like
check the source if there's any comments
but i would check the source as well as
think you know you lost us all my term
am i checking now that'll make it fit
forget to you well you can adjust that i
hold the fort for a second how do this
oh the answer is clearly within and
there is no question in the moderator it
says Etienne says I have been able to
implement the custom multi autocomplete
textview fact by a simple pester adapt
stare with a custom tokenizer I was just
wondering is it possible to implement
this using the cursor loader instead I
have not done multi or two complete text
years in order before with on a regular
one no to someone expirience that no I
guess it sounds like it could be
possible instead I mean when are you
doing an autocomplete texture it's
basically a way to asynchronously fire
off a query against your data source
return back a data set to be you need to
provide you with complete suggestions so
you could use the load infrastructure
for doing that stuff but if you've got
it working using probably the 18 query
and I imagine
women then probably stick with that but
I don't see any innately Vantage's to me
yeah she's just posted a stack overflow
link mm-hmm so maybe we can add it to
the comments and see if anyone else can
and another cool don't it later oh yeah
he doing it I just like set text is
final gusta helper method there is set
text which takes text and a buffer type
which isn't final so it just fixes the
buffer type on the text you're passing
you and what is in plus it is lift take
em off the time there's a long file
who's that with a crazy a droid cake I
guess me your mini its management yeah
get the Rope 10m yeah 10 million on
their downloads this is well Timmy lead
an attack normal so it's just a cassette
text its final because apart still above
type normal but if you want to override
site excuse set text which takes the
string and the button type rich is it
because set Texas remote able oh no it's
not is it yeah he difference was as well
I hope so yeah you just know that set
text is remote yeah miss be ready remote
viewer could be might be some reflection
stuff going on the background as an
unknown Bernie have a question so we
miss yall come in and thinks they
finished off the moderator yeah can we
fly for her today hey I've got some
question here please and it's a bit
about the Securities caching you had
earlier i was wondering because i'm
developing some framework where
the developer that useless framework
needs to make some configuration files
so you need to give the framework some
key value pairs somehow and I've
wondered where would I let the
developers all this since if I
understood it right if he put it to
three sources every other app could
access it we are code because they are a
private to that so and of course that
also what you mentioned earlier I know
that anywhere where I stored on the
device it won't be safe it just obvious
guided them out but where could I let me
pull it so that it's at least so much
obfuscated that another app couldn't
access it we are cold so real question
what you mean by it's in the resource is
another app will be able to access it
via as far as the air perhaps that's the
first question if I gotta try right
another app can have access to the
resources of another app we are the
package manager class so another aapko
just I thought about some XML file that
stores the configuration but that way
another app could just loaded via
package manager class mm-hmm did I get
that right or the summaries of your
resources which are accessible mean
that's how you can write a third party
launcher for example because you can
access the each apks like icon resource
and things like this and I forget you
guys remember there's some areas of your
resources which aren't public well
report so much are an iconic offhand
remember which is which is anyone going
I just one was Kevin's rapidly googling
beyond that I mean any code resources or
it's going to be private to the
application like could you force them to
implement an interface or something like
this instead yeah I caught but I thought
it might be a bit more handy for them if
they since i only need key value pairs
if they could place it something some
nonsense what was that great britain
assets so assets isn't readable which
resources is
isn't it okay because as I looked you
can get from the package manager the
resource and from the resource class you
can also access the SS directory but
I've might got that bro I remember ye
access assets or is even in Bristol or
maybe friday i can't remember there is i
fought for the worst one area which is
public my narrative where's my heart
member of hand which is which didn't you
guys know you don't and so it's unlike
client secret or something like this
that they need to have in their
application or an identifier or some
thought sorry see what is the key that
if a you turn it and yet first some
server address that i need to stall that
shouldn't be so sensitive and some kind
of application ID to authenticate
against the server so calm I just define
it in code can't you tell a hashmap and
just yeah yeah it could but I I thought
it might be a bit more handy father
developers if they use the framework and
they don't need to write because at the
mom they don't need to write any other
code and so this would be just for
configuration implementing interface or
searches yeah would work so if you're on
a framework and I didn't have to run the
code what is your friend won't do
synchronizing it's for should
synchronize java objects to serve and
transparently so actually there should
be only less code as less code as
possible needed from the developer I
wouldn't mind a dancing something to
code for configuration here's a good
also tied check stuff yeah it's done the
way most i've seen to be doing it like a
Maps API and like backup server so
there's a metadata tag in your manifest
right yeah that's that's also what I
thought about the first place but yeah
then I read that you connect
we have the package manager another a
pencil I thought it might be nice if at
least other halves can't access the key
via code so of course as long as it's on
the device you can get it out there but
perhaps not via or another application
yes yeah it comes down to the you know I
guess that's the convention so i think
i'll be the conventional way most people
will be used to it but yeah if you would
much rather you making much harder the
cut for apps to kind of reader then yeah
you can put in code okay thanks guys you
open already any other questions i've
seen as a few in the G+ thread as well
most words about the privacy issues
protecting our application is there
someone how to style the preference
widgets from preference activity I find
it difficult to style the list of radio
buttons from a list preference for
example in earnest no I was always be
absolutely not I always just bake my own
I felt that kind of that was the point
of preference activity just kind of does
everything for you and you said
adequately over yeah I can choose do
things like period I've been yeah why
would you want to be yet I think Chris
is this something you might be able to
do where you could insert a theme at
runtime I don't know I don't know what
the preference styles are actually
probably though bit numb internal so
that you can override them I can't I
don't know I've never done it so I've
never looked yeah i'll be on verge on
the side of not wanting to do that i
think that there's some you know utility
to preferences looking the same and
being operating the same yeah you can
call the choice of light or dark but
that's about it really and there is
something like unified printers as well
if you look at the library unified
preferences that's quite a nice little
library which helps you to do this kind
of thing and produce and you know
fragment-based references which work
cross phones and tablets as well so i
think there's some utility in not doing
this is specific finger to achieve cool
I feel like running out questions this
is anything lightly anyone have any last
questions I think some just put some in
the chat window oh yeah ah guess I'm
just 10 sec okay his one in Java I can
start an application with my person plus
loader is there a way to do it in
Android you can guide you right that was
known didn't read write an article on
the Android developer blog about this
that was for loading class files off the
internet and the load inside your
application with the class loader but
not a customer class lever much for the
idea person class area every means by a
custom class loader this is I need a
gentle sorry I didn't you change the
class over no I didn't tell you the
things might be a dalvik thing oh this
next page of the moderator question is
as well as you can ask me more
us that was is it anyway to accept some
parts of a software update objectors
asked Bob like pvp I know Nautilus
you're holding your own kind of update
mechanism but not for your place talk
and last question aside from South hands
is now that the protection level
definition of change configuration has
been changed in jelly bean breaking apps
like more local too is there a way to
change the device language to a custom
one such as Welsh anyone other non
something remember so is this one of the
settings that I wasn't aware this is one
of the settings that moved from local
settings to global settings and had
their protection changed allows enough
kids to modify the current configuration
such as low since API level one what's
changed about it the protection level he
says I guess you need to go to system
signature we did the security settings
stuff that's why I fought yeah with the
multi-user stuff we may be does my gut
feeling of what the answer is in which
case it's the you know same arts as we
get before that many of these things
it's not that we've changed you guys
that wasn't a very well to find API for
it you weren't supposed to be able to do
this it's just that you were able to
pope certain settings in thing and they
will change but it wasn't like it was a
well-defined API that we guaranteed not
to break it's so changing device
language and locale from inside and out
doesn't sound like something yeah I went
to send the users he appropriate
screening setting 350 fine intent
absolutely i mean i know for apps like
locale that's not gonna be exactly the
behavior won't but that's what the
platform suppose okay which case is gone
three o'clock we've run out of questions
in the moderator on all the G+ stream I
can finally get this echo out of my ear
yeah that's good and thank you for
joining us today i'll be back at an all
time for next week's office hours but
then i'm guessing they'll be on hiatus
for Christmas for the
on a break for a couple of weeks and
we're back well will decide by next week
thank you all for joining us again and
uh catch you cheers nice thank you guys
thank you